please welcome cecilia and pernilla
how do you guys feel
you made the documentary
now that it's this runaway success
how do you feel that it's this exposed
this out there and everybody's talking
about it
well i would say we're completely
overwhelmed about all like
attention around it i mean i would never
imagine this in a million years be
happening and cecilia
why do you think that this guy
is able to take advantage of people
the way he does
i think it's just the mastermind at what
he does and
he is not alone either in when he's
doing these type of crimes like he has a
whole team with him and he has something
about him that he has that has been
keeping him going and going and going
and no one has stopped him
that's the thing i'm curious
do either of you have any patterns or
anything in your history
that would make you an easy target or
make you susceptible
to
behavior like this
absolutely not i would say the only
thing that is the same pattern me and
cecilia have is that we're loving and
caring humans
and that is the type of person that he
is attacking i'm like he's an adapter i
mean like he really adapts to you and
your persona and the type of person
that you would like and i think he sees
every opportunity that he can use to be
honest
i mean is it true that like
i can't even handle this that you're
still struggling with the debt it's not
fair and he's still he's still having
stand charges for the criminal sex he
did towards us
so
why
what is that
that is a very good question for the
police i would say because we were
asking the same question we're we're
really asking that question how come
yeah it's it was a golden opportunity
when he was in the documentary as you
can see he was taken in greece like he
was incarcerated
the police in europe could have taken
him at the time and we have no idea why
they just didn't choose to do so uh it's
a mystery so it's such a shame and we
tried our we try our best you know to
get this guy and the team around him
what would you say to him right now
i think i think that he needs help i
really feel that he needs help and i i
feel sorry for him that's what i would
like to say too i feel really really
sorry for him a very empty life that he
has pernilla if he was in front of you
right now what would you say
well i would say that i told him that
i'm going to do everything to let
everyone know who he is and i think i
sort of accomplished that just saying i
told you
mission accomplished mission
accomplished and i do think things
timing is everything maybe it doesn't
happen exactly when you want it but it
will happen and i do believe through
this documentary
the force of change will come so kudos
to you for being a part of it and
telling your stories cecilia one of my
favorite things in the documentary is
you said i don't blame tinder for this
no because i feel these type of people
exist everywhere i could have met simon
in a bar as well like his scam was so
elaborate and you could really feel it
and see it it wasn't online so it isn't
tinder's fault and i think that we're so
loving people i didn't want him to take
that away from us i think it's a
beautiful thing to love love and
continue to do that even though people
are hurting you that for me really is
one of my favorite parts about this and
pernilla
what
cracks of light into beams of rays that
are so powerful
and out of this darkness have you gained
through this experience
well otherwise i've never met you know
like my best friends you know like i'm
sitting here with cecilia she's my
absolute best friend we always say we
wish
we met in another way but i always want
to believe that everything happens for a
reason and i honestly don't know what i
would do in my life without having
athena cecilia in it
i mean so
i came right back oh god cornell has
saved me she's saved me so many times
through the years so yeah
thank you cecilia and pranila so much
the tinder swindler is available now on
netflix if you don't already know it and
haven't already seen it because it's the
thing everybody is talking about and
still unveiling as we speak thank you
guys so much
[Music]
you